hello and welcome to the 6wx Python
tutorial in this tutorial we're gonna be
discussing one more sort of pop-up user
input functionality with wx-- Python
that's fairly simple to do and that's
gonna be kind of like a multiple choice
box but only you can only choose one so
anyway this is where we left off we'll
just run it real quick it asks you what
your name is will just leave name there
and then do you enjoy and it comes up
here and here's where we are it says
welcome name although it says loser if
you say you don't like W X Python so for
now I'm just gonna hard code Harrison in
there that way I don't have to keep
entering my name and let's begin by
adding one more thing this check box
basically so we're gonna go ahead and do
it is we're gonna put that on the area
of this bracket we're going to put that
where I start coding that right about
here right underneath this last if
statement that we built and to do this
first one either to find a variable just
like you have to every other box in this
case I'm going to call it
choose one box and that's gonna be equal
to W X dot single choice dialog and the
parent to this is going to be none then
we're gonna have the question or what
you want that window to kind of say
basically so we're just going to ask
what is your favorite color then the
next parameter is gonna be the title to
that little pop-up window and since
we're kind of running out of space will
just make it down here and anytime you
have really long parameters you can just
do this and it just puts it on a new
line instead of being like really long
just makes it a lot easier for people to
like read the coding anyway so anything
you just put the title that window here
will just say we'll call it color
question
and then you follow that with an array
of as many items as you want so let's
say we want to have four different
choices so we'll say green red blue and
yellow let's say those are the choices
now you could just leave it at this but
let's define a variable so we get used
to just you know storing these answers
because that's pretty much what you're
going to be doing a whole lot of so
we'll say if choose one box dot show
modal equals W X dot ID okay as an if
they choose okay instead of cancel kind
of like we did with like enter your name
and stuff then what we wanted to store
this in the variable fav color you
obviously call it whatever the heck you
want but fav color seems to make the
most sense and we'll say that's equal to
choose one box dot get string selection
so what was the selected string and
that's so then that'll keep us green as
the selection basically so with that
we'll go ahead and save we'll run it and
what's your name here's and that's just
default of course I do
and then it asks you this it's just like
anything else you can either hit OK or
you can even like double click on the
answer and then up pops your window well
comparison so that's kind of like a
multiple choice input besides like yes
or no so if you wanted like more than
one selection so anyway that was pretty
quick tutorial just on that last thing
and the next tutorial we'll be getting
into some more stuff regarding that
panel and then we'll get into a little
bit more depth and make the hopefully
our program a little bit more exciting
so as always thank you for watching and
until next time